ce coin est minuscule, c'est l'histoire de
ces deux Titans qui se réunissent et
créent la situation où nous pensons que la
hit-girl est cette force imparable de la
nature, mais elle vient de tomber sur quelque chose
qui va l'arrêter, c'est la mère
Russie,
il n'y avait pas de mecs qui  étaient de la taille
d'Olga ou avaient le même genre de
structure AB mais elle est assez
impressionnante la mère que je devrais frapper fille
combat c'est le combat que tout le monde veut
voir ils se réunissent ces deux
forces, il pourrait être d'abord continuer à regarder
cette merde  bientôt vous appelez face à la
frontière mère russie et je suis très
très intense et a pris deux semaines pour filmer
elle mesure six pieds huit ou quelque chose et
des muscles purs et travailler avec elle et
nous sommes si drôles parce que vous avez
amusé Jimmy conçu les combats  pour que
nous jouions parmi les forces des rushes
et que nous vous montrions que quel que soit le mouvement de mindy
adware, leur arme qu'elle a utilisée mère
russie avait une réponse, je suis un grand
partisan de laisser les acteurs faire
autant que  ils le peuvent parce que pour moi, le
public ne paie pas pour voir un double cascadeur,
généralement, une fille à succès peut tuer tout le monde, mais
le plus drôle, c'est qu'elle est tellement
adolescente parce qu'il y a comme si je venais de mourir, je
savais déjà qu'il lançait des couteaux la
mère Russie essuyez-en quelques-uns  off Mindy
essaie de grimper au mur et Mère
Russie l'attrape et la claque
c'est un combat très brutal mais vous
ne pouvez pas avoir frappé les filles Seth trop de
fois,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la chienne d'adrénaline